wow
Nvidia you know in a way I'm actually
impressed your sheer lack of concern for
any of your mainstream customers it's
kind of an achievement like you're in a
race with wizard of the coast to see who
can tick off their fan base the fastest
and you're out to prove you'll do
anything to win I mean nvidia's
practically admitted they'd rather rely
on software tricks than give us faster
hardware and the 40 series is not just
overpriced it's more like hate priced
and the thing is guys we know that
getting outraged is not going to do
anything and you know it's not going to
do anything the 4060 TI was panned by
critics and the community alike and
still cost $400 somehow but if you want
us to get mad then okay let's get mad
because the RTX 4060 is yet another nail
in the world's most overpriced coffin
and we're tired of it and we're also
tired of not telling you about our
sponsor super micro the newest additions
to Super micro's h13 servers are here
powered by amd's epic 904 processors
with up to 128 cores an amount of cores
that we're not sure is legal get blazing
fast performance that handles even the
most memory intensive workloads click
the link below and upgrade your
infrastructure today like hit bigger
titanium your brother the 4060 is built
on nvidia's 8106 GPU and has 8 gigs of
gddr6 memory so what are we losing when
we downgrade to a feebler metal well for
starters 29% of our Cuda cores for the
the main course 33% fewer rate tracing
intenser course and for dessert a sweet
$100 price cut that makes it am I
reading this correctly less expensive
than the last gen card it replaces but
it's not all roses those core counts
aren't just lower than the 4060 TI
they're lower than the last gen 3060
also lower than last gen is the memory
bus width still at a piddly 128 bits oh
and don't forget they half the number of
pcie lanes which could cause a
bottleneck for those still on PCI gen 3
platforms but look sayth Nvidia the
clock speeds are up and there was a big
bump to L2 cach to make up for the dire
lack of memory bandwidth spoiler alert
it doesn't to prove it we put the 4060
and its competition through a brutal
series of tests 1,00 total tests that's
right the labs is in full swing baby
we've included a bunch of cards that are
still topping the steam Hardware charts
the best of amds bang for the buck
lineup and an Intel Arc a750 for good
measure and as you probably already
figured out from the specs this is not a
4K card so let's get these results out
of the way quick the 4060 only touched
60 average FPS in F1 and was anywhere
from me to barely playable in our other
titles you could have a decent
experience in older games or with
settings dialed back to medium or low
but if you want to play on high you'll
have to resort to techniques some
consider to be
unnatural sticking with Pure
rasterization Performance for now though
let's talk 1080p Nvidia made it very
clear with the 4060 TI that they were
not trying to make a card that is
significantly more capable than its
predecessor and with the 4060 Nvidia has
extended their not trying streak in
cyberpunk 2077 the 4060 fails to outpace
the 3060 TI which is like the one card
you'd hope that this thing at least ties
with right to add insult to injury it
even falls behind the now 30 to $50
cheaper RX 7600 from team red then we
see the same story in f122 where the 460
sits just 10% ahead of its last gen
direct counterpart the 3060 the real
star of the show then again is the last
gen 6700 XT which cranks out 42% more
frames than the 4060 and at the time of
writing can be purchased for just $10
more in The Last of Us Part One the 4060
at least beats its direct team red
competitor RX 6700 but but again fails
to overcome the 360 GTI and the more
tests we ran the more true our
observations became this thing is so bad
that if I didn't know any better I'd say
Nvidia didn't even bother to Benchmark
to price this thing accordingly to peek
at Vulcan performance we included Red
Dead Redemption 2 where the story mostly
stays the same but the ark a750 shows up
with some impressive performance then in
Forza the 4060 finally eats its way
ahead of the 36 DTI yay I guess and
returnal just confirms what we already
know again
overall the 4060 offers very little in
performance over its direct team red
competitor and it does so at a 20%
premium in price I hope the story
changes when we look at 1440p nope we
actually see the gap between the 3060 TI
and the 4060 increase in several games
and the gap between team red and Nvidia
gets no wider and just like we saw in
our review of the 4060 TI the 67 XT is
Far and Away the most sensible option
for gamers looking for Max Bank for the
buck thanks in no small part to its 12
GB of vram to be clear 8 GB is fine for
most things today but that's unlikely to
stay true forever unlike the pricing on
water bottles at LTT store.com they're
the same price no matter what size you
like and mystery bottles are 10 bucks
off if you don't care about the color
but wait maybe there's a justification
for all of this a master plan I mean
we're 5 years into nvidia's Graphics
reinvented R Trace future can a cheaper
60 series card give mainstream Gamers a
taste of that technology as it turns out
cutting so many RT cores negates any
generational gain over the 3060 TI even
if there is an improvement over the 3060
at least it still beats any of the AMD
cards in its price bracket but the frame
rate hit from turning on Ray tracing
even at 1080p just might not be worth
the bump and visual Fidelity for many
gamers of course Nvidia does also have
dlss and frame Jen
and we do have to give credit where it's
due here when set to the Quality preset
in most games dlss nvidia's AI upscaling
technique is near indistinguishable from
standard rendering if you know where to
look you can find Visual anomalies but
it's gotten good enough over the last
few years that you pretty much need to
be looking for them and the performance
gains are very substantial this is where
Nvidia wants to steer the discussion and
for good reason using d s s at 1440p we
are seeing excellent gains in
performance with the 4060 finally
convincingly pulling ahead of last
generation thanks to one of dlss latest
tricks frame gen frame gen Smooths
animations by creating new frames in
between the natively rendered ones
though it should be noted that frame
generation comes with downsides like
higher latency and also just not being
magic for example with frame gen 4K
gaming is possible on these cards but we
know from our test that if you have less
than 30 native FPS it's really not the
best playing experience you can go see
our experiments in the video Linked In
the description with that said in older
games or at lower settings I could see
Gamers using nvidia's machine learning
AI Tom Foolery to run this thing at 4K
the problem is it's limited to like a
couple dozen games so moving on to
productivity a traditional strong point
for NVIDIA blender sees the 4060 look
fairly capable for a mainstream card and
the same goes for spec view perf where
it's clear that the 128bit memory bus is
a real problem though it's worth noting
this Benchmark is getting a little long
in the tooth we are also working on
getting some results from Da Vinci
resolve but at the time of review driver
issues stood in our way speaking of
issues what about the issue of expensive
power whether gaming or running full Bor
applications like the rest of the 40
series The 4060 sips power f-122 brings
it all the way up to its rated power but
that's Just5 Watts a significant drop
from its Thai clad brother and even less
than amd's 7600
in fact it's less than a 3050 if the
price of power is a concern where you
live then the 4060 actually could offer
a decent value this is probably where
the card shines its brightest and thanks
to sipping power The Thermals on these
Asus dual cards we got for testing are
also great with temps never exceeding
73° on the Hotpot which was kind of a
lot of words to say Nvidia doesn't care
about you when they can't book enough
Fab capacity to serve the far more
lucrative AI customers that rocketed
their valuation Beyond a trillion
dollars earlier this month but we gave
this wet fart of a GPU a full review
treatment anyway in hopes that sometime
in the future it'll come down in price
and make sense to buy that's that's just
the best we can do which we know is kind
of lame we said we were going to get mad
today but we're just out of gas at this
point and I feel like a lot of you must
be in the same boat I mean at a certain
point Nvidia is going to drive their
customers past anger all the way to
apathy and if there's one piece of
advice that we can give Nvidia just
don't let that happen no at least if
someone's angry at me I still know they
care they're invested in the
relationship they're holding on hoping
it's going to get better if they stop
giving a crap that's when I'll know that
the end is coming but you know what you
didn't see coming this segue to our
sponsor delete me in a time when
companies are constantly sharing your
personal information online without your
consent is e to get discouraged feels
like there's nothing you can do until
you hear about the sponsor of this video
delete me delete me will help you find
hundreds of online profiles sharing your
personal information which could be used
by scammers to hit you with a barrage of
Robo calls and spam emails and in more
extreme cases it could even lead to
identity theft or fraud which are bad
removing all this information by
yourself would be a huge task and take
many hours but with delete me software
and team of experts it can be done in
minutes on average delete me finds and
removes over 2,000 pieces of data per
customer in their first 2 years so if
you want to get your personal
information removed from search results
on the web go to join delet me.com Linus
Tech tips and use code LTT for 20% off
if you guys enjoyed this video why not
watch our review of the RX
7600 especially with the recent price
drop it's become even more compelling
and there are some cards featured in
that review that we couldn't include
here